yo on some comedy [ __ ] what'd you think
of a louis winning comedy album of the
year is he officially uncanceled
i think i think that that's like
a move towards that for sure yeah yeah i
thought it was really interesting
because like once you win this major
award from like a major governing body
yeah it's basically them being like oh
yeah you're back in the thing yeah
like i forgot when that happened to mel
gibson someone like i think he won a
major award or someone like testified on
his behalf in front of the academy they
were like forgive him he's sorry it's
not his fault yeah and then he kind of
got like uncanceled from it i think it
also could be
them testing the waters like if there's
a big reaction to this tons of pushback
they whoever they is like the hollywood
uh you know approval board
they might go okay maybe it's not ready
but
if he goes he drops it and everybody's
kind of okay with it and they celebrate
it they're like okay maybe we could work
with this guy again he could but mel
gibson's like he i guess he's uncanceled
in that sense maybe but he's still
nobody he's not the same it's not the
same also his star compared to what it
was is way less mel un-canceled himself
i think when he did that uh passion of
the christ
because he did the movie without anybody
like didn't he fund that independently
and the ship made crazy bread right
crazy so it was like
i think that there are people looking at
it going well people have said worse
things that have made less money well no
he that was before the jew hate that was
the first time we were like does this
guy hate jews no no no no no no he made
yes correct akash is correct no i
thought he blew up first he blew up no
no he had the
thing the cop thing was no the wife
thing that was funny to me the wife
thing was like oh no 2010 or something
after all the other [ __ ] and everybody's
like i can't believe he's saying these
things about black people and i was like
who who do you think hates jews and
loves black people who's that guy
i don't think that exists
very obvious black people
[Laughter]
but yeah he he had apocalypto that
apparently slept
but he made it but nobody really cares
it's not like he's a mega star anymore
louis i think is going to be the same he
out there he could win a grammy but when
his grammy equals sales
like the guy who won best album is
probably great but i know who he was
john batiste i'm also all this [ __ ]
don't know new music but no i feel
washed bro it's wild it's either we're
washed or
everything is such in its own vacuum
that you're just not aware of what's
going on in like traditional mainstream
scenes
because
i've heard of john bautis i don't know a
lot of the song from the ship maybe if i
hear the big one i'll listen to it even
with the
the people who won the oscars
some of these movies i didn't even i
haven't heard of
so is is it that that industry is
failing or those industries are failing
or are we completely detached i think
the fact that we're detached lets you
know that it's failing a little bit
ah like you should be able to hold on to
us a little longer before everybody
would just know
there's just less things yeah and the
fact that we're all kind of in our own
vacuum is part of the reason they're
failing yeah it's i don't think it's
completely failing i'm sure they're
making money still but like the fact
that none of us knew how much longer do
movies exist
i'm curious about this eight years
do you think
they'll be around what do you mean like
a long time that form it's just a tv
movie but it's just movies the
theatrical experience will suffer so
they'll watch these indie movies like
koda
at your house and you're going to watch
marvel you know
call that a 90-minute tv show well well
here's the thing like
the movie itself i don't know it's if
it's advantageous to make a movie
instead of a tv show
because if the movie is successful right
i guess you can make sequels to the
movie shore but like the tv show run it
right have two season threes and four
season five seasons true detective is
a bunch of movies each season is a long
movie yeah so why not just make the tv
shows and if we really like it we want
to spend more time in it i wonder if
movies just become antiquated the way we
tell stories is just through tv shows
it's either super short or super long
you're spending 200 million dollars to
make a movie you don't think you can
spend that on a tv show think about most
features that you see are written by one
person
loan in their place and then boom has
this perfect
you know two-hour thing that it exists
and it puts their name on it yeah and a
tv show i mean you can write a pilot and
then blow up but that's a whole team
that's
that's a business that you have to do to
continue a show so a lot of people just
like that form what if it just becomes
like pixar disney are the only and like
cartoons are the only times you see like
movies anymore and then everything else
just tv shows
maybe there's like one consolidated
story that you just want to tell like
yeah what about like story things like
how does koda become a series i don't
know what code is it won the oscar yeah
i don't know what it is but i don't know
who's in it it's guys know what that is
no i've never seen it children of deaf
adults
[Music]
it's a beautiful story apparently it's
[ __ ] it's about it's parallel
that came to my show in san antonio
apparently it's fire and i think i can
almost why there's a bunch of [ __ ]
adults moaning the whole goddamn time
jesus no but also for like the indie
world like small art house films like
you can't make small art house whole
multi-season series so you'll always
have
an opportunity making a movie eight
years
i hear all of that
how much longer for movie theaters four
years
i love the movie theater
but
i don't know if they can make their
money back yeah
unless you're a major franchise unless
it's marvel and even those movies ain't
slapping like they used to i just don't
know if it's it's worth it my prediction
they're gonna have to let the studios
open up movie theaters so disney buys
movie theaters and there's a disney
store to buy pixar stuff marvel stuff
in there as well
and those things can work because it's
separated right so yeah you create the
disney world experience so when the kids
go they can buy a t-shirt they can buy
their dolls they can buy the toys
correct
okay then what happens for the adult
movies well we don't need to buy that
and how many of those disney theaters
can you make
no all all good points they're going to
be in like
shopping centers where it's a whole
thing for adults they're gonna get
bars and the type of seating to like
order at the table
you